[Music]
great world wide web on the
internet via the camera channel on YouTube
you who listen to us on the radio on TV
tune in to radio TV Câmara an excellent
afternoon we are here to broadcast
so this formal session is very
welcome welcome
[  Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I declare open the solemn session of
the national congress
destined to receive the
constitutional commitment and inauguration
of the Honorable President of the Republic,
Mr. Luiz Inácio Lula da Silva
[Applause  ]
and to the Honorable Vice-President of the
Republic, Mr. Geraldo José Rodrigues
Alckmin, son
elected on October 30, 2022 and
graduated by the Superior
Electoral Court on December 12 of the same
year, their Excellencies and forwarded to the
table the diplomas that will be published in the
form of  internal regiment
make up the table with this presidency the
honorable president of the
republic elected Luiz Inácio Lula da
Silva the Excellency  His Excellency,
Vice-President of the Electoral Republic
of José Rodrigues Filho, His Excellency,
President of the Chamber of
Deputies, Deputy Arthur Lira,
His Excellency, President of the Federal Supreme Court, Minister Rosa Weber, His Excellency, Attorney General
of the Republic, Dr Augusto Haras, His
Excellency, First
Secretary  from the table of the national congress
Deputy Luciano bivar
[Applause]
before we proceed with this
ceremony, I ask everyone's permission
to pay our
posthumous tributes to the great Brazilian and king of
football, Mr. Edson Arantes do
Nascimento, our dear Pelé,
and also the posthumous tributes  His
Holiness Pope Emeritus Benedict XVI,
both deceased in recent days
I propose at this moment that we remain in a
position of respect to observe a
minute of silence
I thank you all and at this moment
I invite you at
this moment I invite you
still in a position of respect to
sing the national anthem  executed  by the
band of the Marine Corps
[Music]
[Applause]
I invite everyone to remain in a position
of respect for the constitutional commitment
I invite the Honorable President of the
Republic elected Mr.
constitution
observe the laws promote the general good of
the Brazilian people
sustained the union the integrity and
independence of Brazil
[Applause]
[Music]
listening to the honorable Vice President
of the Republic elected you  Geraldo
José Rodrigues Alckmin son hasty
constitutional commitment
I promise to
defend and comply with the constitution
observe the laws promote the general good of
the Brazilian people uphold the union the
integrity and independence of Brazil
[Applause]
with the powers granted to me
by the Federal Constitution
I declare impossible in
President and Vice President of
the Federative Republic of  Brazil the
Honorable Luiz Inácio Lula
da Silva and the Honorable
Geraldo José Rodrigues
respectively for the
period January 1, 2003 to
January 4, 2017
[Applause]
[Music]
with the word the first
secretary of the board  of the national congress
Deputy Luciano bivar who will
read the term of office
term of office of his Excellency
Luiz Inácio Lula da Silva
and of his Excellency Geraldo José
Alckmin Filho the positions of President and
Vice President of the
Republic at 3 pm on the first of  January and
before the National Congress,
gathered in a joint session of their
plenary houses of the Chamber of Deputies
in this city of Brasília, capital of
the Federative Republic of Brazil, under the
leadership of the National Congress Board
chaired by Mr. Rodrigo Pacheco and
secretary, the first secretary
present here  Deputy Luciano bivar,
with the
President of the Chamber still on the table  that of
the Deputies the President of the Federal Supreme Court
Minister Rosa Weber the
Attorney General of the Republic Augusto
Haras
attended by Messrs Luiz Inácio
Lula da Silva and Geraldo José Rodrigues
Alckmin Filho who under the terms of article
78 of the Federal Constitution were
solemnly sworn in at the  positions of
President and Vice President of the
Republic respectively for which they
were elected on October 30,
2022 and certified by the Superior
Electoral Court on December 12 of the same
year
for the period January 1,
2023 to January 4,
the sworn-in pronounce in the form of the
cited article of the constitution the following
commitment
open quotes
I promise to
uphold and comply with the constitution
observe the laws promote the general good of
the Brazilian people
uphold the union the integrity and
independence of Brazil close quotes and
compliance with the provisions of the article  75
of the common regiment of the national congress
the secret lord  President of
the Federal Senate, Gustavo Afonso
Sabóia Vieira, signed this term, which is
signed by the importers and by the
members of the committee that directed the work of
this session
[Applause]
The term of office will be signed by the
eccentricity,
Mr.  -President of the Republic, for this
presidency, for his honorable
president of the Chamber of Deputies, for his
honorable president of
the Federal Supreme Court, for his
honorable attorney general
of the republic, and for his eccentrism,
first secretary of the board of the
national congress,
President, if you allow me, I will break
the  protocol today to tell a little
story I see here the
ex-governor of Piauí mate
I wanted to tell a story in 1989
I was doing a rally in Piauí it
was a great start then we are going to
walk to São Benedito Church and when we
finish at the beginning of the  citizen gave me
this pen and said that this c  aneta was
for me to sign Posse These are the
elections in 1989
I didn't win the elections in 1989 I didn't
win in 1994
I never saw it I didn't win 98 in 2002 I
won the elections and when I got
here I had forgotten my pen
and signed with the trumpet  from the senator
I signed with the pen here in the senate
now I found the pen and this
pen that Wellington is a tribute
to the people of the State of Piauí
[Applause]
historical fact you
can forget how
I have the honor of giving the floor to the most
excellent president of the republic
Mr Luiz Inácio Lula da Silva
[Applause] Your
Excellency President of
the National Congress
Senator Rodrigo Pacheco Your
Excellency President of the
Chamber of Deputies
Deputy Arthur
selective Madam President of
the Federal Supreme Court Justice Rosa Weber my
dear fellow Vice President of the
Republic Geraldo Alckmin
Ladies and gentlemen  head of states
and government that honor us,
first secretary of the table of the
c  Chamber of Deputies Deputy Luciano
vivar Mr Attorney General of the
Republic Augusto
my dear companion wife janja
our dear companion wife of
Arthur in Alckmin my dear
companion José Sarney President of the
Republic
my dear companion Dilma Rousseff
President of the Republic
[Applause] Your
parliamentarians
ladies and gentlemen  heads of foreign delegation
my friends
For the third time
attend this national congress to
thank the Brazilian people for the vote of
confidence we received  working
if we are here today it is thanks to the
political awareness of
Brazilian society and the democratic front that
we have formed throughout this history that the
electoral campaign
was democracy the great victorious
in this election,
surpassing the greatest mobilization of
public and private resources ever  one
saw the most violet threats to the freedom
of the people the most object campaign of
lies and hate plotted to manipulate and
constrain the Brazilian Electoral
never had State resources been so
distorted into an
authoritarian project of power never had the
public machine been so misguided from the
republican contours never before have
voters been so constrained by
economic power and by lies
disseminated on an industrial scale
despite everything the decision of the ballot boxes
prevailed thanks to an electoral system
internationally recognized for its
effectiveness in attracting and counting
votes was fundamental now the
courageous attitude of the judiciary
especially  of the Superior Electoral Court
[Applause]
to make the truth of the
Runes prevail over the violence of your
tractors
ladies and gentlemen
on returning to this plenary of the Chamber of
Deputies where I participated in the
1988 Constituent Assembly
I remember with emotion the clashes we had
here democratica  mind to
write in the Constitution the broadest
set of individual
and collective social rights for the benefit of the population and
national sovereignty
20 years ago when he was elected
president for the first time alongside
fellow vice-president José Alencar
I started his inauguration speech with the
word  change the change we
wanted was simply to
implement the constitutional prefects
starting with the Right to a dignified life a
dignified life without hunger with access to
employment health and education I
said on that occasion that the mission of
my life would be fulfilled when every
Brazilian man and woman
could do  three meals a day
had to repeat this commitment
today in view of the increase in poverty and the
return of Hunger that we had overcome is
the most serious symptom of the devastation that has
been imposed on the country in recent years today
our message to Brazil is one of hope
rebuilding the  great is difficult of
right of sovereignty and
development that this nation takes
antou from 1988 onwards had been
systematically demolished in
recent years this is difficult for him by
law of national values ​​that will
guide all our efforts
dear friends in 2002 we
should have sold hope
in the sense of overcoming fears in
the face of  unprecedented election of a representative
of the working class to preside over the
destiny of the country in 8 years of government
we made it clear that the fears of the
contrary we would not be here again it
was demonstrated that
a representative of the
working class could be dialoguing with
society to promote the
economic growth of  in a sustainable way for the
benefit of everyone, especially the
most needy, it was demonstrated that it
was indeed possible to govern this country with
the broadest social participation,
including workers and the
poorest in the budget
[Applause]
throughout this election campaign,
Hope shone in the
eyes of a people  suffered as a result
of the destruction of  and public policies that
promoted citizenship the
essential rights to health education
saw the dream of a Generous Homeland that
offers opportunities to its sons and
daughters in which active solidarity is
stronger than individualism
the diagnosis we received from the
transitional government  esaviera
esaviera in Health resources
dismantle education culture people
technology
destroy environmental protection do not
leave the resource to sell school
vaccination public safety protection
of forests and social assistance
disorganized governance of the economy
of public funding of Support  to
companies to entrepreneurs and to
foreign trade they honed
state-owned companies in public banks they delivered
national assets the country's resources
were plundered to quench the stupidity of
private shareholders scientists in
public companies it is about this terrible thing
that I assume the commitment to together with the
Brazilian people
rebuild the country and make  er again in
Brazil of all and for all I would like to
say to the deputies and senators that the
result of our transition that was
coordinated by the high cooperator will be
sent to each Deputy to each Senator to
each Minister of the Supreme Court to each
Minister of the Superior Electoral Court
to  each Minister of the Judiciary Power
each University each
Trade Union Central so that people know
how we found this country and each
one Make your assessment
ladies and gentlemen
in the face of the budgetary disaster that
we received we
presented to the national congress a
proposal that allowed us to support the
immense layer of the population that needs
the state to simply survive
I want to thank the Chamber and the Senate
for the sensitivity
of the Brazilian people I resist the
extremely responsible attitude of
the Federal Supreme Court and the Federal Court of Accounts in
situations that distort
the harmony of powers
I did so
I did  because it would not be fair or right to
ask for patience  for those who are hungry,
no nation has risen up nor will it be able to
serve on the misery of its people the
rights and interests of the population the
strengthening of democracy and the
resumption of national sovereignty will be the
pillars of our government
this commitment begins with the guarantee of
a Bolsa program program  Family
renewed but stronger and fairer to
meet the most needy our
first actions coming to rescue
33 million people from hunger and rescued from
poverty more than 100 million
Brazilian men and women who have borne
the hardest load of the
national destruction project that today without  Ladies and
gentlemen, this electoral process
was also characterized by the contrast between a
different vision of the world, ours centered
on solidarity and
political and social participation for the
democratic definition of the Country's Vitinho, the other
on individualism in the delegation of
politics in the destruction of the State in the name
of  supports individual
freedom the freedom that I have always defended  demos is to
live with dignity fulfilling the right of
expression and demonstration and above all to
organize
the freedom
the freedom they rub is the
vulnerable oppressed massacring opponent and
by the law of the strongest Above the laws
of civilization the name of this is
since the beginning of the journey
wants to see that he should be a candidate on
a broader front than the
political field that I formed while maintaining a firm
commitment to my origins this
front was consolidated to prevent the
return of authoritarianism in the
country as of today the law on access to
information
will again be enforced  fulfilled the
transparency portal will once again fulfill its
role republican controls will once
again be exercised to defend the public interest we
do not carry any spirit of revenge
against those who tried to subjugate the nation
to their personal and ideological designs
but we will guarantee the primary of the law that
erred  will answer for its errors with the
right to full defense within the divine
due process of law
[Applause]
the mandate we have received
from inspired opponents of fascism will be
defended with the powers that the
constitution gives democracy to
hate we will respond with love to lies
with truth to terror and violence we will
respond with laws and their more
harsh consequences on the winds of
redemocratization saying dictatorship never
again today after the terrible challenge we have
overcome we must live Democracy forever
[Applause]
to confirm these words
we will have to Rebuild
democracy in our country on solid foundations democracy
will be  defended by the people insofar as
it will guarantee each and every one of the
rights written in the Constitution
today,
today I am signing measures to
reorganize the structures of the
Executive Branch so that it once again allows
the government to function in a
rational republican and democratic manner to
rescue the role  of
state institutions public banks in company  s
in the country's development to
plan public and
private investments towards
environmentally and socially sustainable economic growth
send by 27 governors
Let's define priority To resume
works and irresponsibly paralyzed works
that are more than 14 thousand in the country Let's
take back my house mine  life and
structure a new pac to generate
jobs at the speed Brazil wants
and needs we will seek financing and
national and international cooperation
for investment to boost the
domestic consumer market develop
trade exports services
agriculture and Industry public banks
this thought Ben 10 and  companies that
promote growth and innovation such
as Petrobras will play a fundamental role in
this new cycle, while at the same time we will
boost small and medium
-sized companies, potentially the biggest
generators of jobs and income,
entrepreneurship or cooperativism and the
creative economy the wheel of the economy  will
turn around again and Popular consumption will
play a central role in this process Let's
resume the policy of
permanently valuing the minimum wage and be
certain that we will once again put an end
to the shameful daughter of the INSS another
injustice re-established in this time of
destruction
let's have a dialogue  tripartite form
government business union centrals
on a new labor legislation
guaranteeing freedom to undertake
along with social protection is a great
challenge in today's times
ladies and
gentlemen Brazil is too big to
renounce its productive potential it makes no
sense to import fuels
fertilizers platform  of oil
microprocessors
aircraft and satellites we have sufficient
technical capital and market capacity
to resume
industrialization and offer services
at a competitive level Brazil can and
must hold the front line of the
economy Global it
will fit the state of articulation of the
digital transition and bring the industry  bra  sileira
for the 21st century as the
Industrial policy that supports Innovation
stimulates proven cooperation strengthen
Science Technology and Guarantee affects
funding with adequate courses
the future will
belong that invest in the
knowledge industry that will be the object of a
planned National strategy of dialogue with the sector
productive work of research by
universities together with the Ministry of
People, Technology and Innovation
state public banks research promotion agency
no other country has the conditions that
Brazil has to become a great
environmental power based on the
creativity of the bioeconomy and the
ventures of luck biodiversity
we are going to start the ecological energy transition from
agriculture to
sustainable agriculture and mining
stronger family farming and
a greener industry
our goal is to achieve zero deforestation
in the amazon zero greenhouse gas
emissions in the energy matrix
[Applause] in
addition to  es  to encourage the reuse of
degraded pastures Brazil does not need to
unmark to maintain and expand its
agricultural frontier strategy it is not
necessary to cut down any of them just replant
the 30 million degraded land activities
that we will be able to live
without cutting down wood without burning
and without having to  invade our biomes
[Applause]
yes we will encourage prosperity in the
land freedom and opportunity to create
planting and harvesting will
continue to be our objective what
we cannot accept is that it is a
lawless land we will not tolerate violence
against small people deforestation and
degradation  of the environment that has already caused so much harm
to our country
This is one of the reasons, not the only one, for the
creation of the Ministry of the Indigenous Peoples.
is a new area of
Environmental Protection to these Brazilian men and women
we owe respect and co  m they
owe a historic debt
let's revoke all the injustices
committed against indigenous peoples
dear friends and friends
a nation is not measured only by
statistics no matter how impressive it
is just like human beings a nation
truly expresses itself through the soul of
its people there is a  of Brazil resides in the
unparalleled diversity of our people
and our cultural manifestations
we are refounding the Ministry of
Culture with the vision of returning more
intensely to the
Cultural Incentive and Access Policies interrupted
by the device in recent years a
democratic cultural policy cannot
fear the  criticism in electing favorites that
sprout all the flowers and
harvest all the fruits of our creativity that
everyone can from them
it is not admissible that blacks and browns
continue to be the poor oppressed majority
of a country built with sweat and blood
from African crevices we created the ministry
of  promotion of racial equality to
expand the policy  ethics of quotas in
universities and public service, in addition
to resuming policies aimed at
black and brown people in health, education and
culture
[Applause] it
is unacceptable that women receive
less than men performing the same
function that is not recognized without
any respect  a sexist political world that
has been based with impunity in the streets and
at work that has made a victim of
violence inside and outside the home We are
also refounding the
women's ministry to demolish this
centuries-old castle of inequality and prejudice
[Applause]
there will be no true justice in a
country and that a single human being is
wronged, it will be up to the Ministry of
Human Rights to ensure and act so that
each citizen has his or her rights
respected in accessing public services
and private individuals in protecting
against prejudice or before public authority.
our
dear democracy,
the Ministry of Justice and Public Security
will act to harmonize the  The federal powers and
entities with the aim of
promoting peace where it is most urgent
in poor communities among the family
vulnerable to Organized Crime the
militias and violence
I have it wherever it comes from we are
revoking the criminals decree to
expand access to weapons  and ammunition
that so much insecurity
[Applause]
that so much insecurity and so much harm
caused to the Brazilian family Brazil
does not want and does not need weapons in the hands
of the People Brazil needs security
Brazil has a book on education and
culture so that we can  May it be a
fairer country
under the protection of God
inaugurated this mandate reaffirming that
in
Brazil faith can be present in all
dwellings at different times churches
In this country everyone will be able to
freely exercise their religiosity network
ladies and gentlemen the danger that
encloses has been marked  for one of the greatest
tragedies in history the
covid-19 pandemic and no other country the
number of fatal victims was so high
proportionally to the population
as in Brazil one of the countries most
prepared to face
thanks to the competence of our
unified health system and the competence
of our people to vaccinate
[Applause]
this paradox
this paradox can only be explained by the
criminal attitude of an insensitive obscurantist legationist government
Responsibility for this genocide will have
to be determined to Life
[Applause]
what is up to us at the moment
solidarity To the relatives parents orphans
brothers and sisters of almost 700 thousand victims
of the pandemic the SUS is probably
the most democratic of the institutions
created by the constitution of 88
certainly  for that reason it has been the most
persecuted since then and has also been the
most affected by a stupidity
called the cat ceiling that we will have to revoke
let's recompose a health launch
to guarantee basic assistance the
popular pharmacy promote access to
specialized medicine let's recompose the
budget of the  education
investing in more universities in education
technician at the Universal University of
internet access in the expansion of
day care centers and full-time public education
This is the investment that
will truly lead to the
development of the country
the model that we propose approved at the ballot box
does require a commitment to
responsibility,
credibility and predictability and
that  we are not going to give up, it was with
fiscal and monetary budgetary Realism
seeking stability by controlling the
infraction and respecting the contracts that we
govern in this country we cannot do
otherwise we do have an obligation to do
better than we did for hours and
gentlemen the eyes of the world were
focused on the  Brazil in these elections,
the world hopes that Brazil will once again be
a leader in the fight against
climate change and an example of a
socially responsible country capable of
promoting economic growth with
income distribution, fighting hunger
and poverty within the democratic process
Our protagonism  will be realized by the
rec  The foundation of South American Integration
from Mercosur the revitalization of the
South and farther away from the
Sovereign articulation of our region
on this basis we will be able to rebuild
looking at the active and Haughty dialogue with the
United States The European Community
China the countries of the East and others
global actors strengthening the brics and
cooperation with African countries and
breaking the isolation to which the country has been
subjected in recent
times Brazil has to say master of itself
master of its destiny It has to go back to being
a sovereign country we are responsible for the
greatest  part of the Amazon and across vast
biomes of large aquifers already the lives of
women oil and a source of
clean energy with sovereignty and responsibility
we will be respected to share
this Greatness with humanity in
solidarity never consumption
the relevance of the election in Brazil
finally refers to the threats  that the
democratic model has been facing
around the planet,
a fearless authoritarian wave is being
articulated  We defend the penalty of freedom of expression
by means of technological means that do
not submit to transparent controls
,
aware that it is urgent that we create a
democratic distance from affecting
reliable information and
holding the media responsible for the parents
of the poison of hatred and  lies are
inoculated This is the
civilizing challenge in the same way as the
operations of the wars of thematic crisis
and hunger and it gives the planet
the conviction that politics at its
highest and despite all its
limitations is the best way to  the
dialogue between the divergent interests
for the peaceful construction of consensus
denying politics and devaluing and
criminalizing it is the path of Barbalho
and tyranny
[Applause]
my most important mission from
today will be to honor the trust received and
correspond to the hopes of a
suffering people who never lost faith in the future
nor their ability to overcome
challenges with the strength of the people and blessings.
Thank you very much
[Applause]
[Applause] Your
Excellency the President of
the Federative Republic of Brazil Luiz
Inácio Lula da Silva Your Excellency
Vice President of the Federative Republic
of Brazil Geraldo Alckmin
President of the  Chamber of Deputies
federal deputy Arthur Lira,
president of the Federal Supreme Court
Minister Rosa Weber, first
secretary of the board of the national congress,
federal deputy Luciano guivar,
attorney general of the republic, dr
Augusto Aras, my greeting my
greetings to the family
Mrs. Rosângela Lula da
Silva First Lady and Mrs. Maria
Lúcia Guimarães Ribeiro Alckmin
Ladies and Gentlemen Heads of State and
Deputy Government Heads of State Heads
of Legislative Power Ministers of
Foreign Affairs Special
Envoys Representatives of
International Organizations  yours and ambassadors
a greeting to the former president of
the Federative Republic of Brazil Mr
José Sarney the former President of the
Federative Republic of Brazil Mrs Dilma
Rousseff gentlemen and ladies senators male and female
senators federal deputies federal deputies
ministers of state
appointed
the President of the Superior Court
Electoral Minister Alexandre de Moraes
Mr. President of the Superior Madam
President of the Superior Court of
Justice Minister Maria Teresa de Assis
Moura
Mr. President of the
Superior Labor Court Minister Lélio Bentes
Correia gentlemen state governors
invited authorities present
on January 1, 2003 exactly
20 years ago  In this same Plenary,
Luiz Inácio Lula da Silva was sworn in
as the thirty-fifth President
of the Federative Republic of Brazil.
and after Luiz Inácio Lula da
Silva as the thirty-ninth President of
the Federative Republic of Brazil and
Geraldo Alckmin as his vice-president,
there is a feeling of Renewed confidence
that we are facing two
experienced, capable and skilled public figures Your
Excellency President Lula returns to
Palácio do Planalto with the experience of
eight years of Mandate that stood out
for social inclusion for
economic growth by respect for institutions
and returns alongside Geraldo Alckmin
former governor of the State of São Paulo
former opponent in the
2006 presidential elections and now his deputy
in a clear sign that the
country's interest is beyond and above
party issues a sign that it is necessary to
join forces for Brazil
the beginning of a new government is a time for
renewal of Esperança da Esperança in
a more inclusive country safe
democratic and fair as  With every new
beginning, Brazil gains strength and is
filled with the expectations of those who were successful.
ignited with another chance a
chance to do one more chance to do
better in the 2022 elections
brazilian democracy was tested and it came out
victorious it is possible that it was the
most important electoral process in
our history after redemocratization
time will tell the institutions were  able
to guarantee the will of
Popular sovereignty that was manifested through the
votes in the electoral process and resulted
in the majority choice of the Broad front
defended by the victorious ticket and here is a
record of recognition by this
National Congress of the electoral justice
of our country in the person of Minister
Alexandre  de Moraes president of
the Superior Electoral Court
[Applause]
Mr. President Lula Mr.
Vice-President Alckmin Brazil
chose you as the highest authorities of
the Executive Branch to lead a nation
of more than 200 million people the new
government arrives with complex challenges such
as unifying a  Brazil polarized
guarantee social commitments and government  Bringing
the country together for a common goal with fiscal responsibility
is imperative and urgent to
reconcile Brazilians who
disagreed about the country's direction to
encourage acts of generosity to
discourage revanchism to curb
acts of violence with absolute rigor to
restore the truth to
strengthen the freedom of the press to
honor  the constitution and venerate
Democracy Brazil Mr President
calls for structural changes
social aspirations need to be fulfilled
there is no time to lose Brazilians who
need us very much public agents
because they are hungry they live in misery they suffer
from inequalities we representatives
of the powers of the Republic need
work together to find
ways that guarantee equality,
solidarity and dignity for our people,
for each of the Brazilian men and women
who live here, without discrimination and
always with privileges the Brazilian situation is
still
deeply marked by the
health crisis of covid-19 a pand  emia left
far-reaching economic and social marks, in
addition to loss and repair of
lives in homes throughout Brazil, I cannot
make this statement to honor the
memory of the victims of the pandemic and their
families without making a record to
health professionals in Brazil that
the essence of  Solidarity of
Brazilians and Brazilians to all
health professionals our
thanks and after the pandemic the
economic crisis was a reality in all
countries of the world around here we are once again
living with the old enemy inflation
and also with its medicine Bitter
interest  high jobs were lost
companies were closed and Brazilians
saw their purchasing power diminished the
economic agenda of the new government needs to
find the balance between
monetary and social fiscal policy so
that Brazil can grow again and generate
jobs work is dignity  and this
national congress will be on standby
to offer all
necessary legislative overtures.  o for us to move forward in the development agenda,
the last few years have also
been globally marked by
several warning signs In terms of
climate and environmental issues, here in Brazil we
witness changes in rainfall patterns, in
addition to the increase in fires and the
illegal deforestation of our forests,
this problem cannot be denied  on the
contrary, it must be assumed and faced
in addition to recovering
Brazil's image in the world to reinforce the
national commitment to
sustainable practices It is a great opportunity
towards a green economy Brazil has
a vast amount of natural resources that
put us at an advantage in the
exploration of clean energy
from green hydrogen carbon credits among
many other possibilities with
planning and good practices we can be
a world reference in
sustainable development and
environmental preservation
Lula needs strong investments in
infrastructure recall
Juscelino Kubitschek's vision in sen  believed that
Brazil could reduce
social inequalities by developing
industrialization by promoting
interiorization and national integration
this maxim was true at that time
and remains a reality today Brazil
needs to invest in
energy sanitation transport logistics
housing
telecommunications to be competitive  a giant
that needs to be integrated, but there is no
point in investing in this entire
structure if it does not reach the
most distant people or the people who need it most.
of assistance
we need to grow from the inside out
we need to invest in the interior
we need to look inside the country and
bring solutions the truth ladies and
gentlemen is that investments demand
resources and this is a challenge
for the sworn in president Lula and
vice president Geraldo Alckmin is
need to move forward  In a National tax
we do not have a bureaucratic collection system we
need to have it and
simplify it to allow for more
social justice this reform along with the
elaboration of a new one ended the sufiscal
are the priority guidelines of this
National Congress in 2023 thinking about the
future we need to look more closely  care
for education
there is no prosperous horizon for any
country if there is no effective investment
in education the Brazil we deserve involves
training young people by
guaranteeing a quality educational environment for
our boys and girls we must
film the commitment of president Lula
vice-president  President Alckmin so that
this generation
from zero to 18 years of age in Brazil does not lack anything, our
children and young people need education,
lunch, school supplies, sports, culture,
arts, medical assistance,
psychological assistance, psychiatric and
social assistance, in addition to theoretical teaching,
Brazilian education must encompass
concepts  from city  ania diversity
respect ethics we finally need to form
citizens and when talking about education, it
highlights the importance of valuing
Culture in our country
rich in diversity and a world reference
in the arts and here we allow the actress
Fernanda Montenegro to be invited  which says a country without
culture is a country without education
from the seat he occupies allow me to make a
brief record of the performance of
the Brazilian parliament in the last two years
in which I had the honor of presiding over the Federal Senate
and the National Congress the
legislative power was resilient and vigilant
he acted with moderation when
tempers were high he knew how to provide a
balanced environment to test
legislative measures of
public interest Mr President Mr
Vice President Your Excellencies
found a Progressive
reformist Parliament that defends women that
fights racism that shows
concern for environmental causes a
power  legislature that approved
legal milestones such as changes in railroad sanitation,
cabotage,
court-supervised reorganization and bankruptcy citations laws
a National Congress eager for
Brazil to reach the maximum of its
potential with a legal end that
guarantees legal security at the same
time  in which it makes its development possible on
the part of the
Legislative Power I want to assure you that the
spirit of Brazilian parliamentarians is one
of cooperation so much so true is this
cooperation that even before the
new elected government takes office we opened a dialogue with
the transitional government to approve
constitutional amendment number 126  of 2022
arising from the so-called transition PEC, the
commitment of
the National Congress in the series was absolutely commendable the approval
of the proposal that prevented the reduction already
in this month of January of the amount paid to the
beneficiary families of the Brazil aid
that will be again titled the family allowance, we
believe that only the  sum of
partners is able to put us on the path
of social justice and equal
opportunities Martin Luther King at the
apex of the apex of his defense of
civil rights above all the right to equality
said Mr. President has the
Audacity to believe that people
everywhere can have three
meals a day for their  bodies to
have education and culture for their minds
and dignity equality and freedom for
their spirits Congress is par
excellence the place where the diversity
of interests can seek
convergence I am sure that the
common desire of the government that takes office today and
of the legislature that in  it starts soon it's
similar to martin luther
king's dream we want to take care of the bodies
minds
spirits of all brazilian men and women
the project is used but we have
a very rich country capable of great
deeds in this solemn moment in which the
three powers of the Republic meet  are
gathered at this congress in harmony
and balance, I want to conclude by
reaffirming our commitment to persevere  troubled with
democracy and its institutions
part of this commitment
consists of adherence to the commandment of
cooperation and balance between
powers an imperative condition for the
rigidity of the Republic
dialogue respect moderation These are the
pillars for us to have effective
stability and to be able to fulfill what
Brazilian society  awaits us
facing the real problems of Brazil
the time is for pacification let's leave to the
past everything that
divides us we look to the future as a
new opportunity a fresh start let's do
different let's do more let's do better the
future is drawn in the present the time to
change the future of our nation is now let's
not miss this opportunity
we need to guarantee the union of our
people so that we can rescue the
prominence of our nation from this
territory Worthy of the greatest Nations in the
world football country Samba country country
of Joy country blessed by its
nature  we are the homeland of Ayrton Senna
and Pelé the biggest names in  the
world sport of the 20th century
fantastic brazilians who spread the
message of peace and care for the
future of our children around the world
president Lula we
believe that your election
also represents the yearning for the public policies
claimed by our population,
especially the most
disadvantaged segments and  who so strongly
distinguished his previous passages
through the presidency of the republic I am
sure that someone like you who has
accumulated all the difficulties
throughout his life
will know how to face the real urgent
problems of our population to
end president Lula I quote here one
of the most important political leaders of
that country  Ulisses Guimarães who in one of
his speeches warned us the
mortal enemy of man is misery more
miserable than the miserable is the
society that does not put an end to misery
thank you for the presence of the
national authorities who are here imbued with the
purpose of National Union
I also thank the  author
International ages that were present
honored us at this moment of inauguration,
allow me to give special thanks in this
last year of the Bicentennial of the
Independence of Brazil to His
Excellency President Marcelo Rebelo de Souza of
Our Motherland Portugal, who also
equally honor us with their presence.
all in 2023 a 2023 full of
peace achievements in addition to much
prosperity I declare on
God's blessings the presence closed Thank you very much
ladies and gentlemen guests we
kindly ask you to remain
in your seats until the
members of the board and foreign authorities of
this plenary leave